kostenlos
die ohren hatte ich wieder normal fahren
und beende das sind ja alle besoffen
oder unser kader ist so also noch
besoffen oder sagt meine freunde stehen
es ist gerade gamescom und wir haben
zwei tage schon hinter uns und das war
wirklich schön
ich habe das geht bis preis gehört zu
haben sondern auch ich mal
wir sind so eine katze über so eine
dreiecks heute mit sofa kater wir alle
gleich laufen seine stunde herum wieso
leichen com oder eine stimme bruder was
los kaum wissen wir dass die kamera an
ist also heute ist das thema drei anti
kater kommt jetzt die beiden glücklichen
es geht wurde und später losgeht
wir haben die behörde begraben
eigentlich müssen wir uns selber helfen
hat war wirklich schön dass sie das
gesagt hatte gab ja auch mal so schlecht
sprünge das euch kurz schlecht wird zwei
minuten und dann seid ihr wieder gut
drauf guckt man das ist doch mal eine
tolle nach so vielen freunden drei
komplexe ballern können wir man jetzt
endlich mal die auswirkungen live sehen
also sehen wir aus es ist ein gift
alkohol nichts angesetzt ihr könnt euch
das leben oder die messe zeit eures
lebens ist es mal so eine 50 50-chance
trinken feiern tanzen und jede menge
spaß
hallo leute und herzlich willkommen wenn
wir einmal sagen
und jetzt wünschen wir euch spaß bei 3
cocktail kopfschmerzen was die
lautstärke störte stimme ich zu taten
sind als und pfeffer wodka hella oliven
tomaten wäre wenn es das letzte mal
gekocht
[Musik]
die schülerin ist es nicht dabei war
heute haben sich die suchtkranken
schwachen magen
es kam zu uns bringen und da hab ich
gern einmal daneben
kaffee schokolade was ist das pulver
auch noch das kann mal passieren bis zu
620 ohne gucken schnitt ich habe astra
und unterbietet damit respekt ist
motivierter vorstellbar wenn zwei
staaten und nicht immer schafft damit
man sowas sagen kann - umso teurer das
gründungsvorhaben sc motive sagt das
beste linke weil irgendwas mit so kopf
in red bull energy durch den tag
ich hatte uns mut geholt aber ich habe
deswegen kommt ja nicht mit hey du hast
du du spinnst beschwert es bei mir das
ist komische zutaten selbst das alles
zusammen löschen
ok frau tomatenmark mussten glutamat für
auswärtiges entwicklung arbeitet dann
ist das bier ist ein alkohol meine
zutaten sind frischer orangensaft ist
der kann sich so viel vitamin c und das
ist ja wenn man verkatert aufwacht hat
man immer sofort boxen flugzeug zu
trinken also was ich fühle mich so was
von belog und betrog bananen milchraum
chilli champagner und green coffee wo
ich richtig überrascht war ich habe noch
nie gut also ich habe noch ganz genau
ich bin eigentlich ein training mit
kaffee machen dachte aber es ist
auch schwerpunkt und dann sehe ich so
einfach eine kaffee limonade die also
ist ja nicht mal kultur oder so lange
ist es soll ungefähr seines caravan pack
april event wie ein doppelter espresso
mit erfrischender zitrone würzen pina
ebenso an wo es witziger irgendwann
gehandelt
und ich hab ein frank schott eben dahin
dass wir alle für dieses gegangen und
ausbildung zu machen
das aber hat dafür habe ich sie hat an
sich geglaubt und hat gedacht sie
schafft das mal eben so ganz locker
leichter ich würde sagen wir fangen
jetzt an machen konnte die bank
[Musik]
und wieder ein japanisches walfangschiff
löcher rein wenn wir uns diese gurken
sticks und taxi darüber also ich habe
nie gemacht
die idee du hast mein gesicht ist mein
kapital nicht was machst du da schon
besser an als auf die suche nach dem
glas gegangen bist du wolltest
die mussten wir kurz auch nicht den
boden als dort damit erhält weil es hier
und mal da musst du dir da musst du nur
so ganz habe ich dabei ist so kaum
draußen ich werde dir nicht so viel
verdienen ich hauptprobe wird ein
bisschen groß sind um ein willst du mich
verarschen
das ist eine perfekte männern ein hallo
trotters ich hoffe das wird echt oman
ist wirklich pech aber die hat dieses
diese perfekte konsistenz nicht anfassen
also ich schneide jetzt meine orangen
zur hälfte und vanessa wieder probiert
einem youtuber zu machen
[Musik]
kann ich nicht ein stück premiere macht
bibel kalt und katzenjammer
[Musik]
aber es gibt ein partner ist ja immer
gut sport zu machen weiß ganz genau was
wir alle machen pizza netflix und
einfach und nun sehen sie zwei top
youtuber die sich gegenseitig mit ihren
kooperationen aufziehen
selbstverständlich nach vertont freddy
durch das gemacht
[Gelächter]
die leute können ja auch nicht besser
anguckt ein netz auto das wir machen von
dem rechten noch weiter verwerten das
war einer auf branche also weg macht in
der mitte genau die mandarine stadt
zumal clementina oder orange sie alle
haben eines gemeinsam
der weiße haut zwischen der schale und
der essbaren frucht wissenschaftlich
wird die weiße haut als make up oder
albedo bezeichnet
und kelly ist so dumm und ist sie auch
noch aber das war doch nicht mit absicht
doch weist nein doch nein doch hört auf
euch zu streiten ich will wissen wie die
cocktails werden
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
das ist aus dramaturgischen gründen
lasse ich jetzt einfach mal ein papst
sehen einfach so stehen
trinkst du die ganze zeit auch weil ich
schon seit drei tagen im video
geschnitten habe und was haben hüte
werde
okay da seid ihr bereit für champions
schon noch eine ganze flasche fonds
kaufen können opel hat zehn euro
gekostet als überlegen
was unspektakulär
ja das funktioniert in einem japanischen
messer aber ich habe ja noch fertig ne
[Musik]
japanischen messe heute muss man richtig
was erzählst du scheiße das ist ja
einfach darin gespielt habt ihr ein
ihr freund eine beziehung
mein gott ich habe genauso viel von der
[Gelächter]
mein gott wie sieht es denn hier schon
wieder aus höher ein bisschen chaotisch
bisschen chaotisch bei diesem zimmer
chaotisch aus es ist ein chaos das ist
ein schweinestall doch wirklich als ob
man noch so viel zu trinken hier ich
habe euch eine pfütze gemacht
[Musik]
du hast du mit mit mit energy drink
gemixt
ja ich weiß dass dreht man rum wenn man
sollte zeigen will was sich gehört ins
meer
[Musik]
und jetzt sind wir fertig und ich würde
sagen wir fangen mit training kann weil
sonst hat er keinen mehr auf den ski an
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
erklären habe ich erkläre gerne dazu
passt auf dem kater
ich denke da ruft früh stromberg wird
sich gut die leute die im wald wurden
weil es nicht wo du bist mit der natur
verbunden und deswegen trinken wir heute
ab was einer waschechten mir glaubt es
kaum sein
ich war rechtfertigt sehen weil ich es
so lange zubereitet haben dass wir
finden konnten und ist meine zweite
melone in format und muss sagen ich muss
sagen ich bin angekommen
ich glaube dass all diese stoffe
berechnungen würde ich hier und jetzt
könnt ihr endlich sehen was sie
angerichtet hat
es ist wirklich es ist sowas im
historischen hässlich und ich habe den
deckel dieser melonen ausgehöhlt und
habe einen freundlichen guten morgen
herr von nebenan
[Applaus]
konzentration her vor ist mit vorsicht
zu genießen sie ein ritual was du
eigentlich bloß nicht gehört hätten
das ist okay war
das ist ritual die stunde gar nicht
verlieren wollte also ich schmecke
nichts gemerkt dass das ritual durch
dass du durchkommst und danach gehst du
ein zuwachs gab es so schlecht
danach geht es in den beiden weiteres
ritual was uns verbunden hat müssen sie
zu einer einheit gemacht wird wir sind
eigentlich immer - so wie ein summe
river das gesicht waschen können und
energie und es ist wirklich nicht so
schlecht wie du denkst
kennst du das wenn du alle farben
zusammen wird so schmeckt wird alle
fragen der mann dieses grau braun kriegt
was so irgendwie braun des jahres das
sind mir nicht braun zweiter schlug sich
im red bull die definition nicht ganz
verstanden also die mixtur der ließ halt
noch nicht im ritual angekommen weist
die braucht seine zeit schlug jetzt
sieht sie was wir sehen
genau das war sogar stützen hier
dieses papier ist einfach mein format
wie kommst hier kenne so was ja auch
wirklich kein bock aber ich denke mal
tomaten nicht schon dass wir so lange
redet dass mir die ohren abfallen jetzt
kommt auch noch die unmotivierte kelly
aber das wird auch noch besser mit ihr
er sagt ja immer wieder dass die folgen
auch lang sein können also wäre ich lese
einmal in den kommentaren dass dieser
hintere teil euch komplett gelangweilt
hat denn es ist so anstrengend dieser
scheiße zu schneiden und besonders wenn
er einfach nichts passiert hofer
erklärungen
ich hoffe euch gefällt das video
trotzdem ich verabschiede mich hier
schon an dieser stelle und wünsche euch
noch viel spaß bei dieser schlaf parade
wie ich sie gerne nenne also helfern
es ist eigentlich ein platz besser katar
version also das tomatenmark ein
bisschen intensiveren geschmack von
tomatensaft ist meistens ein bisschen
langweilig des chili das schaf das
belebt den geist lausanne den alkohol so
ein bisschen draußen den restalkohol
aber gleichzeitig bei wodka und damit
der kater weg geht und man wieder auf
einen normalen die alltags pegel kommt
ja das waren die ich wirklich hast du
musst du selber ja nicht essen ich
dachte mir das dann nutzen wir so als ob
man da ist ja so eine hohe bedeutung und
alles figuren wurden kaffee schokolade
weiß dass er so ich dachte halt ich
dachte so kaffee schokolade so süß und
scharf wie ich mit dem mit dem blut was
wir wollten mal runter läuft und dem
fest der dümmste massenmörder aller
zeiten
wir haben sie endlich gefasst keiner
konnte sagen das ist also die übrigen
frauen in zukunft das nicht aus
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
also ich hoffe wir sehen heute habe ich
auch ein paar komponenten im staat
ich habe meine haare richtig geil ich
finde man am besten jetzt schon
also ich habe gedacht es gibt ja so was
das heißt mimosa und weil man
verkaterten im moose ist ist das ja ich
super und wenn man aufsteht klammen
kater dann will man ja auf jeden fall
und jetzt mal was richtiges trinken und
etwas kaltes ich habe diesen kaffee
davor nämlich rein gemacht weil man ja
machen werden muss und dann habe ich
diesen gesunden ingolstadt noch gemacht
oder bei mir stand eigentlich
entschlossen das ist das erste ist was
man am tag bringt wenn man auch wirklich
so eine
keiner macht die scheiße das ist nur so
diese instrument kommt schon für die
stories -
ja die schwarz-weißen sie kauft doch
kein so scheiße teuer und fucking aber
sie sind gesund ich meine dass das zeug
drin
und weil wir natürlich entsprechend über
sind zehn euro champagner aus um ihn zu
führen vielleicht eine banane damit man
halt auch schnell was sind so zucker
warten bei trauben geil irgendwelche mal
bock auf süßes jetzt hast du eine
anzeige gesehen
und hier ist natürlich weiß man so ich
habe gesagt dass ich mich nicht mehr
melde aber es ist ein scheiß ernst 55
sekunden natürlich gerade erst über
meinen cocktail und er fragt schon ob
wir trinken dürfen bei ihm haben wir
mindestens drei minuten zuhören müssen
was mir scheiß er sich ausgedacht hat
dreht euch leute nicht dreht euch hier
alles was ich hasse es in einem ding
muss ich was ich muss sagen der luchs
hat vom nahen müssen so ich weiß nicht
mehr
ja ich weiß aber nicht was das gemacht
hat wie sie nach vorne geht und wer zu
zeigen
ich weiß aber nicht mal irgendwas muss
ja irgendwann erschöpft gewesen
das ungerührt ich muss leider also nun
gibt es die statuten die stimme der
schiri gibt es zumindest eine gibt okay
das ist jetzt wirklich das letzte mal
aber wie traurig ist dass es keiner sich
mit mir freuen
ich freue mich dafür mit mir selber ja
und dann sehen wir uns auch das nächste
mal wieder und bist als ich mit alkohol
kater ist kein spaß und monika trapp
trinkwasser und auf jeden fall mehr
alkohol